qu'avez-vous fait ma psyché ça va
nous avons presque glissé dans le paquet et votre
bas-ventre et vous allez
transporter quelque chose de très spécial des thés
hé vous parlez anglais non non non parlez
anglais oui oui emmenez-moi à l'hôpital maintenant
quelqu'un le remet  de drogue à l'intérieur de moi
j'ai besoin que vous l'enleviez ça coule
on estime que la plupart des êtres humains
n'utilisent que dix pour cent de la capacité du cerveau
imaginez si nous pouvions accéder à cent
pour cent des choses intéressantes commencent à
se produire oui professeur Norman je m'appelle
Lucy je viens de tout lire  tes recherches sur
le cerveau humain c'est un peu
rudimentaire mais tu es sur la bonne
voie je te remercie j'ai accès à vingt
huit pour cent de ma capacité cérébrale
je ressens tout depuis quand as tu
commencé à écrire le chinois il n'y a pas
ce qui se passe quand elle  atteint 100
% n'a aucune idée de toutes ces connaissances que
vous pouvez débloquer des secrets qui vont au-delà de
nos limiteurs Je ne suis même pas sûr que l'
humanité soit prête [ __ ]
c'est comme si toutes les choses qui me rendent
humain s'estompent
tu